our solar system hosts for rocky planets
Mercury Venus Earth and Mars but there
should have been fired
billions of years ago planets were
forming all over our solar system but
there was an area in between Mars and
Jupiter where the gravity of Jupiter
pretty much pulled apart anything that
tried to form today the scattered
remains of a failed rocky planet fill
this gravitational battleground its
debris forms a vast band of rubble
around the Sun called the asteroid belt
rocks inside the asteroid belt range in
size from grains of sand to giant
boulders hundreds of miles wide but I
first started studying astronomy we
called them rocks dry rocks now we
understand that there may be a lot of
water maybe even liquid water on some of
the larger asteroids our newfound
understanding of asteroid water comes
from a study of meteorites tiny
fragments from the asteroid belt that
sometimes fall to earth I've got a
sample of a meteorite called
a carbonaceous chondrite and it looks
and feels rather dry to the touch but I
can tell you that that sample actually
contains about twenty percent by weight
water even crushing doesn't release the
hidden moisture because the water is
chemically bound to the minerals that
make up the rock and let's see if we can
get some heat going here on earth on our
burner heat allows the water molecules
to break their chemical bonds and escape
as vapor
look at all that water coming out just
this small sample of meteorite is
driving off all of this water so here is
direct tangible evidence of the of the
amount of water that astonishing amount
of water that can be delivered to the
earth from the impact of asteroids four
billion years ago countless asteroids
smashed into Earth during the late heavy
bombardment each impact generates an
intense burst of heat that releases the
water trapped inside the asteroid water
vapor then falls back to the ground as
rain and this same water still exists
today in our oceans our rivers
and even in our coffee cups when we look
at this fingerprint of deuterium on the
Earth's water it better matches
meteorites and asteroids that does
comets so yes certainly some of the
water came from comets but the majority
of water in your body right now
amazingly may have come from the
asteroid belt